the Chobe River in northern Botswana
forms the country's natural border with
Namibia while fishing and agriculture
dominate on the Namibian side Botswana
has put its side of the river under
protection that was 50 years ago and
made chobe Botswana's first national
park early morning is perfect for
watching wildlife
the mad light on the sky beautiful 70
thousand jobs in Botswana depend on the
tourists who visit the country's
wildlife reserves but forego be much it
easy working as a park ranger is much
more than just a way to earn money
the national pike together with the
animals means everything it means
everything to vote on others tourism so
conservation is the most important thing
we have to love our animals we have to
protect the environment and I'm happy to
be one of those people that do that in
our country the high-pitched whine of an
electric motor this game viewer is one
of the first electric Safari vehicles on
the African continent
and besides e-cars chobe game lodge also
boasts a fleet of silent solar-powered
boats and besides that it's also managed
to cut down on 95% of its waste and
garbage running ecotourism and focusing
on it is going to be paramount your
traveler these days are becoming also
more responsible and they would like to
to make sure that that if they do go on
holiday that they do support sustainable
holiday destinations and operators with
two million visitors every year
Botswana's tourist industry ranked
second after diamond mining
conservationists around the world
command its complete ban on hunting and
fierce stance against poaching across
africa hunting and the growing human
population are forcing wildlife out of
their natural habitats many of the most
fabled species have been driven to the
brink of extinction conservationist
Robert Sutcliffe who collaborates with
the Chobe game lodge is worried even in
Botswana road construction poses a
serious threat to wildlife
one of the main reasons is habitat loss
other development throughout a lot of
areas being locked for forward has been
cleared for farming and then development
like was singing khazzani that are
pushing these animals out of the areas
that I normally inhabit in 2012 chobe
river and its national park became the
center of the curve angle Zambezi
transform tier Conservation Area this is
the home of one quarter of the global
population of endangered African Wild
Dogs
it's Africa's largest reserve and spans
five countries the aim to enable animals
to migrate naturally and freely the
effort is paid off while giraffe numbers
are dwindling in other parts of Africa
here there still numerous combining
ecotourism and conservation is helping
the species survive
Robert Sutcliffe thinks Chobe National
Park is on the right track that it's so
important that we work to try to
conserve the abyss population that this
you know could be a stronghold for for
giraffe and it's also amazing to see
them moving into Zimbabwe moving back
into Botswana and there is no barrier to
their movements there which is wonderful
to see him at roughly 5% of GDP
ecotourism is still in its early stages
in Botswana
but the sector is growing fast providing
a steadily increasing contribution to
the well-being of the country and its
people